wir sprechen hier über die themen die
uns in dieser woche und vor allem an
diesem tag am meisten bewegt haben und
damit möchte ich heute anfangen mich hat
gestern und heute besonders dieses foto
bewegt im backstage bereich wird
mitgefiebert das ist ein foto vom
backstage bereich des trails gestern und
nein es beschäftigt mich nicht weil dort
niemand eine maske trägt oder niemand
abstand hält ich halte das für
vollkommen richtig so sollte unser leben
langsam wieder aussehen ich habe mich
darüber erregt weil da vieles getan wird
aber eben nicht mit gefiebert die drei
kandidaten wollen dass wir ihm zu hören
dass das land ihm zuhört aber sie können
kaum dafür sorgen dass ihre eigenen
leute zu hören wir sehen ob er die in
ihrem handy rum tippt wird den volker
bouffier der kurz davor ist einzunicken
wir sehen hermann groer der irgendwo hin
schaut aber ganz sicherlich aufs duell
nur saß carsten dieck option aber die
kann vermutlich ihr glück wegen der
umfragewerte kaum fassen und wünscht
sich jetzt nur dass dann etwas lockerer
kanzlerkandidat dieser umfang gewährt
hätte dabei gebe es so viel worüber man
sich aufregen könnte und weswegen man
gebannt mit zuschauen könnte aber dann
müsste man die wirklich harten themen
ansprechen für mich gestern das thema
was auf bittere weise nicht angesprochen
wurde war das thema migration das wort
fiel kein einziges mal und vor allem das
was menschen bei migration oft
beunruhigt das thema migration und
kriminalität es wurde zum beispiel
gefragt wo frauen in deutschland sich
besonders unsicher fühlen es war die
antwort lautete an bushaltestellen aber
es wurde nicht darüber gesprochen warum
frauen sich an bushaltestellen denn so
unsicher fühlen denn eines kann man doch
sicher sagen die bushaltestelle ist ganz
sicher nicht das sicherheitsproblem
sondern oft die menschen die dort sind
und dort haben wir ein ganz massives
problem das ist das was mich diese woche
ganz massiv bewegt hat er jedenfalls
hält die menschen die ich auf diesem
foto zu sehen sind jedoch eher
tendenziell gelangweilt gucken dabei
sind sie mitverantwortlich für diese
tabuisierung die du ansprichst
tabuisierung von dingen die bürger
wirklich bewegen und ich glaube ich bin
mir sicher dass wenn die politik weiter
nichts land und weiter die themen die
die bürger wirklich interessieren
ausspart aus ihrer programmatik aus
ihrem aus ihrer kommunikation aus ihrer
diskussion dann kriegen wir noch ganz
düstere zeiten im land ich finde er ein
punkt ganz interessant und da gibt es
tatsächlich um sprache gestern ging es
um die bushaltestellen und nicht um die
menschen und die täter an den
bushaltestellen es gibt weitere
phänomene es gibt den sogenannten lkw
anschlag an dem nach allem was wir
wissen nicht der lkw schuld ist es gibt
die so genannten messerattacken bei
denen oft genug nicht erwähnt wird wer
für diese messe attacken verantwortlich
ist beliebtes beispiel das gibt es nicht
nur der politik das gibt es auch in den
medien in den öffentlich-rechtlichen
besonders vor kurzem messer anschlag in
würzburg da geht jemand in die stadt
ruft allahu akhbar erzählt menschen die
da sagt hinterher das war mein
persönlicher jihad und was lesen wir zb
in der tagesschau suche nach motiv
gestaltet sich schwierig das ist
dasselbe thema ehrenmorde oder als das
sprach sich auch die berliner
integrations enttäuscht davon dass sie
jetzt eigentlich nicht weiß über diese
männer irgendwie besser integrieren
könnte und wollte das auch net
zurückfielen erster linie auf den
kulturellen background was hat ein witz
ist bei keinem ort denn nur passiert
nicht weil die frau eine frau ist
sondern weil sie westliche werte lebt
und da die augen zu verschließen und ich
finde dass das traurige debatte ist ja
aber dass armin laschet oder wenigstens
ein paar wochen das so lang ist's her
meinte 2015 darf sich nicht wiederholen
ist dann ordentlich gescholten worden zu
unrecht und das ist irgendwie vergessen
weil sich auch in die seine partei die
damit fahren deutlich dass leute
herauszuholen und das will niemand
irgendwie leute nicht rausholen dir vor
allem ortskräfte sind für die für
deutschland gearbeitet haben aber jetzt
schon wieder dasselbe zu machen wie 2015
unkontrolliert leute rein zu holen ist
schwierig ja genau das ein ansprechender
vorher entschuldigen sie verheerende
konsequenzen gehabt wir lernen ja jetzt
dass bei den ausgeflogenen aus
afghanistan ausgeflogen menschen gerade
138 glaube ich ortskräfte waren plus
familienangehörige das heißt unter den
grob gesprochen 400.000 wieder
ausgeflogen worden sind waren
verschwindend kleiner anteil derjenigen
die reinhold werden soll drei prozent
ist die zahl 16 inklusion familien warum
weil die politik so lange das thema
verstolpert hat um zu vermeiden dass das
thema afghanische flüchtlinge im
wahlkampf eine rolle spielen und es
stehen es war das war das schlimmste ist
auch dass vier von denen irgendwie
straftäter waren und zwar keine leichten
straftaten die schon mal aus deutschland
abgeschoben wurden nach afghanistan
jetzt zurückkommen und unter ironie des
schicksals reisen all die themen vereint
ist doch dass wir regelmäßig darüber
debattieren wer spendet beifall und
nicht was hat jemand in der sache gesagt
das ja genau das problem und weil man
angst hat von den falschen leuten
beifall zu kriegen oder dafür
verantwortlich gemacht wird von wem man
beifall bekommt deshalb sagt man dinge
nicht die man sagen müsste ich find das
müsste man
zum beispiel ist es doch richtig dass
sich 215 nicht wiederholen darf dass es
heute unterschiede gibt in einer
situation ist richtig aber trifft den
kern nicht denn vergleichen heißt ja
nicht gleichsetzen sicherlich
kontrollverlust darf es nicht geben und
deutschen alleingang darf es nicht erst
sehen sein auch für unterschiedliche
situation glaube dass der entscheidende
begriff der bei den bildern aus
afghanistan und bei den vorstellungen
dass jetzt viele tausend menschen aus
afghanistan
die schutz suchen bei uns sind ist
dieser begriff einfach im kollektiven
bewusstsein von kontrollverlust das ist
2015 und das ist jetzt wieder getriggert
und ich finde es ist ja noch gar nichts
passiert also dass die vier straftäter
dabei waren hat mich schockiert aber ich
würde sagen immerhin sind sie entdeckt
worden und immerhin sind sie entdeckt
worden und können jetzt sozusagen wieder
ins gefängnis kommen dann allerdings
wahrscheinlich wieder nicht abgeschoben
werden das heißt ich glaube viele bürger
die dies beobachtet fühlen sich in so
einer wiederholungsschleife von etwas
schon erlebten aus denen aus dem nicht
die richtige konsequenz gezogen wo das
gibt ja auch keine der politik keine
persönliche verantwortung mehr für den
system also vor weiß ich nicht zehn
jahren 20 jahren ja da ist gerd schröder
losgezogen mit otto schily als dem
innenminister überhaupt der nichts
zugelassen hat der hat im interview über
terrorismus gesagt wer den tod sucht
kann ihn haben hatte ich meine der mann
hat früher mal der reihe verteidigt das
war schon eine kleine wende kennen sie
mit solisten raus warum eigentlich hat
der spd-kanzlerkandidat heute niemanden
für migration und sicherheit und warum
hat auch herr laschet niemand da könnte
er anpassbar und israel haben weil schon
die verbindung aus migration und
sicherheit angegriffen wird als eine
diffamierung kollektivierung aller
menschen die eher sozial aus einem
anderen kulturkreis stammen weil es
irgendjemand an diesem tisch wer dafür
verantwortlich war wer in den flugzeugen
sitzt
ja ich würde sagen aber das war der
professor zu fall würde ich mal sagen
brasilien die hand fiel ausgesucht
worden pragmatisch diejenigen die am
flughafen sozusagen durchgewunken haben
übrigens dann
meistens amerikanische soldaten die an
dem haupttor sozusagen um das ist
dagegen standen und gesagt dann durch
durch nicht durch da und weiß er hat
irgend jemand von euch eine vorstellung
davon wer dafür jetzt die politische
verantwortung und weil ich muss sagen
mir ist es nicht mehr klar wir haben
jetzt hier mehrfach gehört wir müssen
klar sagen 2015 darf sich nicht
wiederholen auf in viel kleinerem
maßstab ist die weit aber das passiert
ja gerade natürlich wie gesagt in viel
kleinerem maßstab aber die kontrolle
darüber wer kommt dazu uns ist ja
offenbar schon wieder nicht ausgeübt
worden also der satz darf sich nicht
wiederholen ist nochmal in kleinerem
maßstab ja schon kommt vollkommen
hinfällig wir haben so viel
staatsversagen gesehen in den letzten
zwei jahren ist hast du noch eine von
was ich ihm dutzend themen was darunter
gekommen ist da wird sich in dieser
legislaturperiode vor der wahl gar
nichts mehr bewegen danach soll zum
untersuchungsausschuss geben ich bin
nicht so überzeugt ob damit energie noch
untersucht wird oder ob es nicht weg
geschoben wird das ist eben das problem
wird wir finden uns ja gerade so in
limbo eben passiert jetzt gar nichts
mehr vier wochen bis zur wahl es kann es
macht doch wenig sinn wenn jetzt mehr
zurücktreten würde oder was hätten jetzt
davon wenn horst seehofer sagt einigen
amt nieder der gratulation aber deswegen
wird das höchstens nach der wahl eben
aufgeholt werden aber die kennen
untersuchen der schlüssel in österreich
drin das hat man
jetzt überraschen
die folgen die das zeitigt ok will jetzt
hc strache gibt es auch noch aber na
also jetzt eben das wird und motiv jetzt
keiner verantwortung an suchen oder wie
auch immer nach sich ziehen das ist das
ganze problem man kann eben nur als
wähler was ich auch nicht behindert im
land sondern seine stimme abgeben nach
der partie wo man sich denkt die macht
hat auch die debatte ist nicht
vorangekommen
man könnte ja grund gründlich
unterscheiden dazwischen einerseits
deutsche staatsangehörige andererseits
ortskräfte raus zu holen die uns
geholfen haben und das wird aber sofort
mit der allgemein eine
flüchtlingspolitik wieder vermischt und
da sind auch durchaus sage jetzt mal was
genau ist eigentlich für migrations
ministerium nach der wahl hat sie das
formuliert also wir wollen migration zum
großen thema machen wir wollen aber
nicht wie die grünen sagen wir trennen
das für deutschland von inneren arbeitet
auch ihr nicht ist ja die frage wie man
in einer
immer mehr aufgaben und integration
dessen aufgabe aber nicht so wie die
grünen sich das vorstellen die wollen
dass wieder völlig zu recht
[Musik]